- [Voiceover] Just 45 minutes
north of the U.S. border
is a city called Langley.
It's a typical city.
There is a casino, tree-lined streets,
and, of course, a Ghanaian tribal chief.
(light upbeat music)
This is Eric Manu.
He works in Langley as a gardener
for this woman, Susan Watson.
In Canada, yard work is
a year-round occupation.
- You'd be surprised how busy
we are during the winter.
- [Voiceover] Back to Eric.
Eric's story began with
a phone call last July.
- Yeah, my uncle died,
and I got a call to take
over that responsibility
as a chief of my community,
and that's in Aboabo Number 2.
- [Voiceover] He said something like:
- Really?
Are you kidding me?
I said, "I'm gonna give it a try."
- [Voiceover] So he went back
to Ghana and became chief,
but he decided to return to Langley,
and this is when Susan got involved,
and where our contemporary story begins.
Everything that happened
after Eric became chief.
- [Eric] I have seen so much in Canada.
That's my own experience,
and I also want my people
to have some kind of opportunity in life.
- [Voiceover] With Susan, Eric is working
on raising funds and collecting donations
to help set up medical
clinics for his tribe
to improve education.
Overall, he's trying to make life better
for his people back home.
- We started the To the
Moon and Back Foundation
to help the people in Ghana.
We've collected more than
two 20-foot containers
full of donated items.
- My journey has been a
very successful journey.
Although I'm a chief in Ghana,
I'm proud working as a gardener
to support and give my
people their exposure.
I'm proud of my community;
I'm proud of my family;
and I'm proud to be an African.
And, I'm proud to be a Ghanaian.
(upbeat music)